We'll begin today with,
uh, uh, in fair, no,
let me say a few things about the poem
in general as the structure of Department
of form or structure. And
then we get into the, uh,
the cantos one, two, three, four,
which have been assigned
to you. Um, I already,
in passing in my introductory remarks,
I did,
I did say something about the title.
As you recall, the title of the poem,
the poem,
we referred to it as the divine comedy.
It should be comedy.
That's what Dante calls it.
And he called it comedy
for a number of reasons.
The first reason is that it
ends in, uh, with in, in,
in happiness.
It's a story that begins with a kind
of a disorder catastrophe if you wish,
the pilgrim who is lost in the woods
and then works himself out toward the
light,
told the truth toward God.
That's so comedy describes the, the, uh,
thematic trajectory of, uh,
the poem. It's, it's, uh,
it's going from one condition to another.
And from this point of view,
it's the very opposite of the tragic
movement in the tragic movement.
You'll always have some kind of initial
state of cohesion or an initial state of
happiness that then goes
on going toward the, uh,
some kind of fatality or a disaster.
Uh,
but it is a second reason for the title
comedy at the second reason is stylistic.
Uh,
Dante,
he calls it a comedy because he
adopt the vernacular first of all,
as opposed their possibility would
have been writing it in Latin,
in a kind of a,
the language of philosophy and the
language of great cultural exchanges,
but it calls it instead,
he uses the Italian vulgar language.
It also means a,
stylistically he adopt a humble style.
You know what the theory of styles is
coming to us from ancient Greece and Rome.
Uh, there are three levels of styles, uh,
three levels of style that is the high,
a tragic style,
the sublime style that describes exactly
the events that involve kings since
style is must have some,
some kind of APP tennis to the
situation that the story describes.
Then there is a middle style or
[inaudible] style and then there is a,
a low style, the style of comedy,
the style. Then did Dante,
uh, with adopts lowly, uh,
that this is a kind of a
peculiar implication for
Dante to call a story such as
his, a comedy. And this is the
implication that are in effect,
he undercuts the idea of a
rigid hierarchy of reality.
There is no such a neat
separation of the high,
the middle and the law that
which is low and humble,
such as the experience is describing or
his own experience and no ordinary human
being of living around the year 1300
who manages to have this extraordinary
experience of going up to see the face
of God and come back to return a call
back two years to, to
tell us about it. Uh,
it's really a sign that the lo can
become high and the high can become law.
That is that a classical, uh,
distinctions that we read,
the of which we read in the poetics of
virustotal that Dante did not know or in
horses poetic heart that Dante
did know, uh, are really,
uh, false. I really user it.
This is not the way to proceed.
So Dante has a number of items that
he's pursuing in calling this text.
Uh, uh, the comedy.
The other thing you have to say about
the formal structure of the poem is you
all know it's divided into three parts,
hell,
purgatory and paradise easy.
Each of them has 33 cantos
with the exception of,
of inferno in federal has 34 cancers,
which means has one can to,
one is we're going to read in a moment
plus 33 they are neatly separated in that
can to one represents and stands
for a kind of general rehearsal.
It's a journey that fails,
downplay the real journey.
We'll begin with Ken too.
So uh,
it has 100 canters but the basic
unit of his narrative is the three.
Number three,
in fact,
it's written in so called a
style or a magical formula.
He devices are so called Delta Rema
that I'm sure you recall from your own
readings in high school or in
other courses that they have even,
which uses the rhyme scheme is
always going to be a, B, a, B, c, B,
and so on. Number three,
once again, is the, the,
uh,
the fundamental symbolic,
a number of division within,
uh, within this text.
What is the reason for this?
There is a large aesthetic reason and
aesthetic reasons, but it can be found,
formulated,
crystallized in a verse
from the Book of Wisdom.
You are God have created everything
according to number measure and weight.
And so the divine comedy has to duplicate
the symmetry and the older and the
harmer he that he thinks
he sees in the universe.
The poem is presented and produced as a
reflection of that superior divine order
of the universe and
wants to be part of it.
So it's both as this kind of ambivalence
to reflect it and become what we call a
Maconomy, uh, the part that
wants to be to a larger, uh,
ho. Uh, so these are the, some general
concerns that you gotta have it now, uh,
about deploying some general ideas that
will help you understand the pattern of
parallelisms that are we
going to find within the poem.
And that can give you one very quickly.
Now in a sense,
I'm really asking you that
when you read the poem,
you should be aware that there is a kind
of linear structure from one to 100,
uh,
and yet within the triple a,
the traditional department hell,
purgatory and paradise there Qantas
that correspond to one another,
10 to six of inferno, uh,
prefigures Canto six Uga,
toto in both of them in turn will
prefigure Canto six of paradise can
[inaudible] and so on. It can
be done, but can 10, 10 and 10,
it can be done in a fairly
systematic way. So, uh, if you wish,
sometimes you could really read, uh,
one, two, three, four and yet one,
one and one which is,
oh,
maybe you wait until the end of the poem
when you have read the whole poem and
then you can go back and read it.
A horizontal is it where as much as
vertically down. So these are some,
some uh,
employee ideas,
general concerns and implications
in Dante's structure of the port.
We begin now with Canto one.
It's a very well known cancer where the,
the step general preamble,
uh,
you know how the poem starts
is I'm just reading the Eh,
the famous lines.
Everybody reads a and everybody probably
remembers in the middle of the journey
of our life,
I came to myself.
Those of you have a different
installation, will nonetheless, uh,
get the gist and it's, it's the
changes. The shifts are really minimal.
I came to myself within a dark
wood where the strict way was lost.
Ah,
her hardest thing it is to tell that would
savage and harsh and then the thought
to which renews my fear so bitter.
It is that death is hardly more.
But to give account of the good,
which I found there,
I will tell of the other
things I noted there.
I cannot write retail how I entered there.
I was so full of sleep at that
moment when I left it through rea.
But when I had reached the foot of
the hill at the end of the valley,
we should pierced my heart with fear.
I looked up and so it's shoulders already
clouded with the beams of the planet
that leads men straight on every road.
Then the fear was quiet to the little
which had continued in the lake of my
heart during the night had spent so PTSD.
And as he who with labeling breath
has escaped from the deep to the shore
terms to the pearls waters and engages.
So my mind,
which was still flight turned
back to look again at the pass,
which never let yet any go live.
It's an a great beginning.
It begins in a very, uh,
extraordinary way, begins with, uh,
in the middle to begin with.
Right? So that's the, the
beginning is in the middle.
The beginning is the present a reality
of the pilgrim who finds himself lost,
but it's more in that first line in
the middle of the journey of our life.
Um,
what is he saying?
I think it's fairly clear the first
conceit and the fundamental conceit of the
poem is that life is a journey,
which means her,
we are always on the way. We don't
know where we're going yet. Uh,
he will find out soon,
which means that we are displaced,
which means we're going to
have an number of adventures.
It means that we are not yet where
we want to be. Life is a journey.
In fact, he will go on. We're only
calling in the middle of the journey.
He also calls it our life that,
that that's a possessive our life.
It's sexist way of establishing one fact
that this is not really yet a unique
experience is something we all share in
something which might also concern us.
That we are also not only he
is in the journey of his life,
but we too are in that journey of
the common journey of her life.
And then in contrast with that,
there is now an autobiographical focus.
There is a stress of I found I are,
I came to myself within
a dark wood and so on. I,
so this is going to be very much the
story once again very much has the Vitor.
Moreover, uh, an autobiographical
story can only be a personal story,
but here the self is going to see the
world is coming to see himself through the
prism of the world.
He will lend to a public space.
The great difference I will
say between the Vita Nuova,
which we just looked at last time,
and the divine comedy is the following.
The Vita Nuova was destined
to fail as a narrative.
Exactly because the, the, the,
the protagonist went home,
uh,
drawing us,
enjoying himself within the solitude,
the inferiority of, uh,
of his own life alive,
which was completely disengaged from
the concerns for the outside the outside
world. The divine comedy starts
exactly with that kind of ship wreck,
the shipwreck of some other intellectual
activities that he will go on
describing. And I will describe it with
you as soon as we read this first slide.
I came to myself in a dark wood.
And you,
if you read a lot of
traditional commentators,
medical treasure commentators
will tell you, oh, well,
Dante is here in the state
of sin are the dark wood, uh,
is really the condition of spiritual.
Maybe despair. He's an impasse,
an impasse.
We know he doesn't know where to go.
I think that this are a little
bit too easy and it's not really,
we have no evidence for this in
the poem yet. We don't know what,
what did we do know is that Dante
law is lost in the landscape.
That is terrifying.
He's caught within it.
He's clueless about how he got there.
I don't even know how he goes on to say,
I don't know how I got myself in that
situation, whatever that situation was.
But he knows one thing that
he wants to get out of it.
He understands that.
He understood.
He does not know yet how he has
to get out of the situation,
but he knows that he has to get out
of it. Impanelment of the wood. Um,
and uh, and then he goes on
our heart. That is et cetera.
So bitter is that death is how the remote,
but to give a count that's
an ex terse it of the good,
which I found there.
I will tell the other things I that
in a way the problem is already over.
He's now shifting from the
narrative of events. You know,
I was lost in the van.
Savage hush would have a night.
His gaze rents this night,
tries to find out.
I cannot see anything beyond
himself immediately he says,
but to tell you the good day noted there
I have to tell you other things that
poem has right from the start,
the double narrative focus.
The first focus is that he's going to
tell us the story of a pilgrim who is
caught in the quarter.
We call the diachronic the time bound.
The daily events are a
number of encounters which
he can not quite this hide as
to their meaning.
So He's,
he's led by virtualizing going to find
out soon but he doesn't understand what's
happening to him.
And then there is the second focus and
it's the focus of the poet who has seen
it all and then enjoys what we would
call an omniscient perspective and the
whole poor and really moves
around this double axis.
The axis of Eh synchronic view synoptic
view of the poet a lot who are senior,
who has, he becomes a port. It was
a pilgrim. Has had this experience.
And then he goes on telling
us about this experience.
That's what I call a synoptic adolescent
narrator. And then, uh, he looks at the,
at the, of what the
pilgrim did not know. This,
a kind of irony in this
discrepancy between the day
or chronic viewpoint of the
pilgrim and the synoptic viewpoint of the,
uh,
of the port,
goes without saying that the
structure is not that neat.
You will see that there are moments when
Dante would go on one's point of view,
will encroach upon the other.
So we'll tell you more about
this particular structure
and now he starts this.
Now let's see what has happened.
Uh,
I can not tell how this is the
second paragraph of installation.
I cannot rightly tell how I enter there.
I will still of sleep at that moment.
It's a kind of torpid, lethargic, uh,
that lack of consciousness that
like the lack of any, everything,
his faculties are dormant. Let's,
let's paraphrase it like that.
When I left the two way,
but when I reached the foot of the hill,
at the end of that Valet,
we should pierced my heart with fear.
I looked up and saw the shoulders already
quoted within the beams and the planet
that leads it in straight on every
road or he does don't has come.
Uh,
dawn breaks and he looks up toward the sun
believing that the natural sunlight is
going to unveil to him the layout of the
land and he may find Eh, uh, uh,
an escape route from this
particular disaster. Uh,
apparently one thing that if this were,
eh,
a platonic narrative,
that point would come to an end right
here because this is what happens in a
platonic narrative. You are in
a cave. You know, we are all,
this is a famous myth of the republic.
We see nothing.
We only see flickers of light.
It's like being at the movies,
flickers of light and real.
There are simulations of the truth that
they are being projected on the side of
the cave. And we mistake
those shadows. Four realities.
If you are really wise and you are a
philosopher than you do know that you can
turn your neck around and find out where
the source of true writers and then you
are saved.
The whole experience of the cave
is predicated on this premise,
that knowledge save shoe,
that knowledge is virtual and knowledge
that save you to the extent in which it
really can heal. But why call?
So what one could call the, the,
the wounds of, uh, of the intellect,
ignorance being the wound
of the intellect, which
knowledge, learning, uh, uh,
education philosophy
could really cure Dan too.
We'll find out very quickly that that is
a false promise that in many ways that
our realities and that his own reality
is going to be a little bit what complex
then are,
what one can find in books,
manuals or philosophy about how we get
saved and how we can save ourselves.
And let's see what he says
and what happens. So he
sees a, he turns toward the,
uh, the light. I saw the already
they've the sunlight and then he,
the he fear are this, this passion, uh,
because it's a passion of the soul.
The fear that paralyzes him
and paralyzes is discernment.
He cannot pay it. It literally stops
him, does not know which way to go.
And it's, it's, it's the,
the overpowering, uh,
passion at this point of the point was
quieted a little which had continued in
the lake of my heart during the night
I spent so PTSD a dark night. What,
what leads some basics done.
This is not a mistake.
Please clear the alluding to the dark
night. This is the dark night of the soul.
This is a spiritual experience that has
found now it's coming to a head. Uh,
Eh,
if you wish.
And this he who the laboring breath
has escaped from the deep to the shore,
turns to the perils of waters and gays
is so my mind, which was still in flight.
You see, look, the whole passage,
I have to tell you this whole,
the two paragraphs with it is
replete with neoplatonic language.
He's talking about himself as if this
were a fright of the soul sought the
flight or the mind, my mind,
which was still in flight.
This is the idea that we have
experience share, pure intellectual,
that kind of experiences that we can
all find when we're reading a book,
we are studying, we are thinking
that mine takes its flight. Okay.
This is an intellectual problem.
Other,
there are other many other terms
here that remind us of the,
his use is deliberate use of neoplatonic
language. For instance, the word woods,
which is it a lot in this, uh,
in in the Italian is Silva, uh,
which translates the Greek Cuellar which
isn't always the prime or matter are
the which then the demiurge
or form and shape reality.
And yet immediately there is
a great shift that I want to,
to focus on briefly after had
rested my weird frame for a little,
I took my way again over the desert slope
keeping all with the lower foot from
and low almost at the beginning of the
steep peppered light and very swift
covered with a spot at hide.
And it did not go from before my face,
but so impeded my way that I
turned many times to go back.
Uh, he has been just now talking
about the flight of the mind.
My mind was still in right.
It's an experience of a shipwreck for
wall that many epic stories begin like
that. Think of the Aeneid, the
shipwreck of in years on the,
on the shores of Africa as
he's about to enter the city.
Dido is about to build,
right?
And that will bring him to a great
revelation and their great love story with
Dido here, there's no such,
such a relief for him.
It's the shipwreck of the mind and mind
that seems to be literally unable to
define both his whereabouts
and his destination.
But as soon as he does,
as soon as he understands that what,
that's what the problem is,
he shifts the language from mind to body.
My weird body,
and this is the great difference between
neoplatonic narratives and Dante's kind
of experience, the intrusion
of body, and what is the body,
what does the body stand for?
The limit of purely intellectual journeys.
The real journey that he has to undertake
is the journey of mind and body.
And their body stands for the
irreducible historicity of oneself.
The stands for one tone. Uh, the reality,
the passions stands for one's hall.
Well,
this is the difference between what
the Greeks understand as the great, uh,
intellectual ventures,
which is one of knowledge and Dante's
idea that the real problems are problems
of the wheel.
We may know all where we are and we all
may understand that we are not happy
with the situation that
we find ourselves with,
but we can look quite solve it
because the problem by knowledge,
because the problems are problems
of willing. What is he doing?
Let me just try to make this very simple.
There are two schemes.
I'm really simplifying it too because I
think this is dramatic enough in and of
itself. I don't have to overdo it
with, with unnecessary complications.
That is a Socratic scheme whereby
all issues or issues of intellectual,
intellectual, the intellectual sought. Uh,
I know, and therefore
I'm virtue. I know, um,
I know what justice is and
the implication is I'm just,
that's a false implication was if,
if I go around the room here and ask you
all to give me a definition of each and
every one or your definition of justice,
you will tell me something that
justice is a justice within the self.
That just is the way I relate to my
family or just as a way or relate to the
city or just as a way to take care of the
problems or whatever of the world that
I find myself in.
Dante,
we'll say this is not the knowledge of
what the definition of justice can not
make you adjust.
The issue is one of willing desire.
The other scheme that downhill poses to
the Socratic idea that all issues are
issues of philosophy or
ratios of knowledge is one
of the will in the letter to
the Romans Send Paul writes the good
that I will do that I do not do the evil
that I would do,
that I do.
He draws attention to the
essential existential problem.
The problem of herself,
my will is divided against itself.
May the the only way I may know where
it, what to do, but I do not know really.
I'm not sure that I will, uh, will
it, that's the fatality of life.
And we all know what's good.
Many of us go around choosing and
doing what we know, uh, where he goes.
So is we know it's good for us.
It's not the best in terms of
our own judgment of situations.
So he's willing and uh,
the perspective of the will
becomes Dante's perspective
in coming to terms with
the limitations of philosophy,
intellectual knowledge. We shall see,
uh, Dante talks about the will
in, in a, in a number of ways.
Last time talking about the Vita Nuova I
was, I began mentioning to you that, uh,
they will,
is even better of course for him then
unwilling and yet the best experiences
life seem to be those a one does
not want to happen to us. As I say,
Dream for instance,
the dream or falling in love or,
or sometimes in the death of the beloved.
No, you don't. He didn't search it.
Didn't not want that death of Beatrice.
It's a way of understanding that
unwilling is as compelling as willing.
And yet he understands that as soon as
he focuses on Beatrice as the figure,
the real contingent,
historical figure of love,
that he has to give a direction
to his own desires that he has to,
to define the wheel so that it's,
you understand what I'm saying?
Uh,
and he understands that too.
So that's already an anticipation of
what, uh, of the problems with the will.
Now he starts exploring other problems.
We should,
we'll see both as they relate to the self,
to the psychology of the character,
but also still relate to politics,
for instance,
to a vision of the world as an act of,
and the projection of our own will that
the world is the way we want it to be.
And that may not to,
to the way in which we relate to problems,
which are problems necessarily problems,
the problems of reality, et cetera.
For the time being though Dan prepare
pigs the will as his own or the body,
his own, uh, his own
perspective. He find out,
he finds out that he can not go up the
hill, that he has seen three beasts,
just paraphrasing the tech's,
a leopard,
a she wolf Elian on that all the lion
and the she wolf will block his, uh,
his journey up. And so he's going right
back where he finds himself in this.
He's now back into the, the, the, the,
the deepest despair possible because
there seems to be now really no exit then,
ah,
he something he sees something when I
was rushing down to the place below the,
appeared before my eyes,
one whose voice seemed weak from long
silence when I saw him in that great
waste. And as you know, because this
is, uh, uh, the first words that he,
Dante was ses have picked, the
pilgrim have pity on me, whoever the,
our tech tried to him shade or real men.
These are the words taken from the psalms,
Ms. Herrera,
of, of, uh, so his, his prostrating of
King David. So He's prostrating yourself.
And that stress this because the voice,
the village voice will constitute
an important strain in this matter.
How does Dante Talk?
That's,
that's one of the ways and we should see
how discreetly it will appear further
down in the poem.
And now the conversation when he meets
is the fear he meets is Virgil. Uh,
no, not, not Maine. Once
I was a man said, look,
we can stop a little bit to reflect on
what is this experience here has been
like,
and we can we define it in some ways.
Dante finds him sort
of lost in a landscape.
He does not know how he got
there. He, the sunlight,
the natural sunlight as the
light of truth by fallen,
which he thinks he can reach the plane
of tools up to the top of the hill,
the top of the mountain from which you can
survey the land and find, uh, the exit.
If I in an escape finder, it's
transcendence, what to call it,
let's call it a way of getting
out of that, this entanglement.
Then he comes right back.
He says for three beasts that we
don't know what they are. They are,
are they sins?
Are there this positions too?
Since there are animals and therefore
their stand for animal projections of our
desires of his desires. The she
wolf, that lion and the leopard.
That's all we can see about them.
Then he meets a,
figured that and can even
know if it's a shade or a man.
His dramatizing what in medieval thought
in medieval literature there it's
called the land of disability.
[inaudible] the land of unlikeness.
He finds himself in a world where
things are not what they seem,
where there seems to be a
disparity between, let's call it,
let's use the literary language
within signs and things,
science and their meanings,
things and what they stand for and part
of his effort is to literally stitch
this to this,
this break between signs and symbols,
meanings and signs.
Stitch them together.
First meeting then this with this figure
by the name of Virgil who will become
his guy. No Man, you know who he
is. He's the author of the need,
but look how he presents himself. I
think it's crucial. You'll pay attention,
but not man.
Once I was man and my parents were wrong.
Bart,
both management by birth,
I was born soup Yulia in Caesar,
which is true though it late in
his time and I lived in Rome.
He gives a biography of himself,
his self presentation
in terms of his life,
the historical circumstances,
and also his works.
That's what we call a miniature biography,
right?
The sense that I came into this world and
somehow this is what it all comes down
to. This is really the sense of my birth
cause he speaks about his own birth,
uh,
our live,
the Roman that the good Augustus in
the time of the false or lion guard.
I was a poet and single that just
sound off on crisis in years.
Who came from Troy after proud
Elian was burned, but you,
why are you returning to such misery?
Why does that not climbed
the delectable mountain,
which is the beginning
and calls or happiness,
meaning the mountain of purgatory
that will take him to Eden,
which is really what all things according
to the biblical version of a cosmology
or things started and he'll say, are you
thou than virgin? Of that famous witch,
that fountain, which pours forth
to reach a stream of speech.
I answered etc. Or glory in light of
where poets let the study and the great
love that has made me search.
They volume my me that what my master and
my author that he from whom I took the
style whose beauty has brought me on.
This is Virgil,
clearly the poet and the
extraordinary recommendation,
which I can tell you as a teacher,
every teacher really would love years
after the students have been with, uh,
starting the teacher is kind
of greater acknowledgement.
How I remember your teaching. That's what
he does. And rhetorical, we'll call it,
uh, uh, the,
the rhetoric of capturing the
benevolence of the interlocutor,
but it's clear that he exchanged between
them and the recognition of Virgil is
as a poet.
And therefore I have to take a few minutes
to tell you a little bit about this.
It's because virtual, we know, uh,
he's the poet of the Aeneid.
Clearly the,
the story of a journey of a
grand epic journey by an ears.
We'll talk a lot about that. The
hope you believing that, that,
that poem if you haven't already.
Um,
but that's not the way he was known.
Virgil was not known this
way in what we call the, um,
the 12th century Europe in the cultural
immediately proceeding Dante's time,
uh,
he virtual more than as a poet
was known as a philosopher.
He was a neoplatonic philosopher
and your platonic philosopher,
they say one who had written a poem,
but the substance of that poem was not
the fiction about the burning of Troy,
the journey of a nes to as an exile who
could go around and looking for a new
land, uh, with his father on
his back. And the kid, uh,
the, the, the, the escape yours by his
hand, it was not nothing like that.
He really had some philosophical depth.
It was a way of acknowledging
that poetry is capable of, of, uh,
providing philosophical illumination.
So what was the,
the philosophical message or
call it neoplatonic those,
it's very much like what they thought
was the, all the say. And that same,
the Odyssey,
the story of Odysseus or Ulysses
who goes from Ithaca to Troy.
And then after 10 years of the
war in Troy goes back to to uh,
ethical techs in 10 more years to do that.
The neoplatonists,
the or Lego risers were viewing that
poem as the metaphor for the journey and
experience of the soul.
It was the story of this.
All that goes from the point of origin.
Once home that's home is
always we call one's home.
That plays at once by one soul is what
one can find oneself somehow, right when,
when he's familiar, comfortable,
wherever. So he left,
he lived lives.
It's like a ghost to trolley goes thrive
and then he has to purify himself in
order to go back as in a circle and
neoplatonic circle back to the point of
origin. This is the
neoplatonic lived all over the,
all this say they would do the same
thing the 12th century. France.
I could give you names if you wish.
Bernard Sylvester Full Gen
z use a little bit earlier.
John of Salisbury, who is an English
manor, the 12th century who goes,
go on writing about the,
are there any or there's a story of a
hero who is born in Troy and then goes
through the stages of life. Each book
represents a stage of life, childhood,
youth maturity with all the temptations
of the thrush to happen with Dido.
Uh, and then he goes back
to two k arrives in Italy.
That's the book six. They will never
really bother reading the other.
The other book,
so the engineer that was viewed as a
philosophical text illustrating the,
the, the pattern and the movement
of life. It was really telling us,
and that's really the promise
of philosophical knowledge.
It really PR that we all
like in years our board,
but with care improvements
can reach the promised land,
Dante changes and this interpretation.
And he changes this interpretation
by making and insisting that you,
that Virgil is a port.
He replaces the philosophical promises
with the idea of poetry in the belief
that poetry is better than philosophy.
And that philosophy can not quite
reach the depth of immense life.
That makes two general promises.
Toy everybody tells us that
we can all be like you, like,
like an ears going from Troy
to Latam. And Nantais says, no,
this is not really say much that say
anything or talk about the reality.
And the individuality of my life.
Poetic language is for him.
The language that addresses these issues
and therefore poor to here is seen as a
version of history. You know, this is,
you had the writer, he says to Virgil,
who wrote that poem dealing with
Roman history, poetry and history,
the deal with the world of contingency
and not the world of universal and the,
and therefore potentially empty
promises. So that's the, the uh,
the great change,
the great new interpretation that
Dante's advancing about a part of virtue.
And what Virgil, we'll tell
him is that, uh, uh, the, uh,
the go on talking about Dante,
we'll call him a master and
a, and author. This is a, uh,
great sage and all that. And
uh, and virtual says to him,
this is very simple.
You must take another road.
You are going the wrong way. This
is not, that's what I call the,
the idea that came to one is
the rehearsal to the whole poem.
It gives the story of a journey,
a journey that fails,
a journey that is a bolted,
that's not the way you go. It's not,
you know, you find yourself lost.
What do you do? You try to
go quickly up to the, uh,
uh, to the destination. You can climb up
the hill and you think you can make it.
No, no, no. Uh,
virtual replies that he has
to go in a different way.
He might reach the same point, the
same destination, the world of justice,
division of God, the idea of
love, the good as he calls it.
But he must go down
that the way up is down.
He has to go through the whole spiral,
through the horrors and the suffering
of hell then reemerged through purgatory
in order to be able to reach the
beatific vision. That's very simple.
The way up is down.
And this is something that,
that marks the difference
between philosophical
presumption and the notion of a
spiritual Christian humility that he
has to pursue and wants to pursue.
So this is, uh, uh, it, the, the, the,
the conversation between them, uh,
goes on with this a prophecy
of the so called Hound,
uh, page 27 line 100. He
says, you know, the, uh,
the world is in such disarray and yet 100,
they're very mysterious and enigmatic
prophecy that will come to when they
discuss by the time we come
to the end of purgatory.
And so now the journey begins.
Then he set out and I came on behind him.
That's the end of Canto one.
And we come to Canton to where now it's
worth the time of the year since this
is, this has to be a historical
irreducible and, and, and, and,
and essentially a biographical
experience that has to be very careful.
He will give us the time,
that precise time and place
of his experience. Uh, we are,
are the poem starts on Good Friday in
the evening of Good Friday of the year
1300. These are the, so it's, it's,
it's a very crystal mimetic we call
it an invitation of Christ kind of
experience because will emerge to
the light to purgatory on Easter,
Easter Sunday. But Dante says, but
why should I take this journey?
It's such extraordinary. You hear
such a, this is the whole brand,
the whole substance of cancer to
ignoring. He as he says, I'm not poor.
Why should I be here? Why
should I go on, uh, uh,
w poet? I'd be in lines 10. You got this,
me consider my strength is a sufficient,
you tell us if the father of
silvers as he went, uh, meaning, uh,
meaning of course and ears, uh, et cetera.
And then you also tell us about the Paul.
Uh,
and he concludes, but I, why should
I go there? Line 32, and who,
granted, I'm not in years, I'm
not Paul. He's, first of all,
these are the coordinates, the imaginative
coordinates for his own journey.
And he is the hero who brings
about the foundation of,
and then Paul the apostle to the gentile,
the 13th apostle who really brings about
who also goes to Rome, but he goes, oh,
the the, the, the, the spiritual domain
of the church. So these are the tool.
So who is he? That's the first question
he must answer. I'm not an ears,
I'm not poor.
The implication is who am I?
This whole part of this story is to find
out who he is and part of this journey
is indeed to find out the part of the
beginning of this journey at least,
is to find out that the poem is written
in order to bring some degree of
redemption and clarity to the world.
He really believes in this in this
way we call salvific role of his own,
of his own voice. Not without
either, not without discouragement,
not without a sense of that.
This may indeed be a proud,
arrogant kind,
sort of a posture.
This whole idea about who he
is is immediately countered
by a reflection on his
own divided we'll line and that
just want to read this thematically.
And there's one, one wheels where
he willed and with new thoughts,
changes purposes.
So he withdraws from what he has begun
such I became on the dock slope for by
thinking of it.
I brought to not the enterprise that
was so hasty in its beginning. Uh,
it will take me really too long to give
you a sense of an appropriate gloss to
this lines. The alliance about
the limitations were willing be,
Dante begins by claiming the importance
of the will in the act of knowledge.
And we do see that he saw
aware of it to your waist.
One detail that I did not
mention you, you, you,
you realize how the pilgrim moves
throughout, uh, in the, in Canto one.
And he will move in December.
We will never talk about it
again. He hobbles in, uh,
in, uh, uh, toward the light
hits. It goes around hobbling.
And that hobbling is part of his being,
being wounded and having a wound
that will, that he must somehow heal,
so it would say, well good. Dante
said, voluntary voluntourist not quite.
That doesn't believe in philosophy
and intellect, not quite.
He believes that the two
faculties of the soul,
intellect and will I like the
feet of one's body. They got,
if you really want to walk
fast at least and safely,
you're going to be using both.
Yeah.
Use the intellect and they will buy
soon as he claims the importance of the
wheel, which this Socratic
experience had somehow neglected.
He goes on reflecting about the
limitations of the will and what are the
limitations. One of it is we all
can be divided against itself.
The second one is that they will need
something to regulate it because I can,
I can. We'll any day I can go this
and that. How do I order what I will?
The third limitation of the will,
and we'll talk more about the company,
some of these aspects, but there's
a third limitation with the will,
is that I can never really go
faster than my home wiggle.
I'm a prisoner or if I believe
that that's all I have,
my where I can't go faster than it.
If the will is weak and slow and divided,
that's what I am.
I can't, I can't go past it. So
some, some of the difficulties.
So he,
he goes Ken to true,
trying to think about I the identity
and the purpose of this journey.
Who am I? I'm not in ears.
I'm not poor then who am I?
That's a great question. And
as soon as he does this, he,
he admits he,
he,
he sheds light on the first
internal issue that he must show.
And an internal issue is
the divided, divided. Well,
we come to Canto three. I'm sorry. There
we go a little, little fast, but that's,
we are, we'll moves
fast. Uh, so, you know,
this is now Dante enters to the hate.
The Gate of hell are the famous, uh,
uh,
inscription through me the way,
pretty scary and that scares
him. Uh, uh, uh, quite a lot.
And Dante meets the first, uh,
the for sinners that he meets
the so called neutral angels can two,
three around line student flooring.
I and I,
my head is circled with said,
master,
what is this are here and who are these
people who seem so mastered by their
pain?
And he said to me,
this miserable state is borne by the
wretched souls of those who live without
disgrace.
And without praise.
They're mixed with a Katif choir
of the angels who are not rebels,
no faithful to God by word
that my Texas for themselves,
the right translation is by themselves.
Because if you are for yourself,
you are for someone.
These are the angels called neutral,
who in the great cosmic battle with
which the world begins between God and,
and the satanic forces just
became spectators just watching.
So that sensation is bear
in Italian says bear Stacy,
which we translate this by themselves.
So taking a separation. In other words,
Dante begins by dramatizing that which
to him is the most serious of sense,
not being disengaged,
not taking sides in the belief that
somehow you wait and see what the outcome
is. And then you can go on taking
sides. That's the, the, the,
the start of this, uh, of this
experience. And then he goes on a wire,
the grievers, and he responds, they
are, have no hope of death, et Cetera.
Our PT and justice despise them.
Let's not talk of them,
but look at them and pass.
There's even name them.
He won't even name them because to name
them will be to bring them into reality.
And then we'll travel at the stands and
is a sign of their way in which they,
the realize the world that
he use the world tool,
a pure show of their own
for their own spectatorship.
So, uh, he, he goes on from here and, uh,
and now, uh, the second action is that he,
he sees Charin the famous, uh, uh,
uh, uh, he goes into the
ferry who will share,
who will ferry the oldest
souls. And, uh, uh,
gives an extraordinary
description of this figure, uh,
and the souls who blasphemed God
and the parents, the humankind.
And then there is an extraordinary
image that I want to read with you when
Dante's to describe the souls and what
he sees as holes that go on the boat of
chairman. This is toward the end of
Canto three lines. Month one, one 12,
and following as in autumn,
the leaves drop off one after the other.
The branch is old.
It spoils on the ground.
So the wicked seed, um, the,
we could see the Adam fling themselves
from that shore one by one at the signal
as a falcon.
And it's recall that's the
part of the dark water.
And behold they've
landed on the other side,
a fresh cloud collect again on this,
my son said,
the culture's master,
all those that die in the wrath of God
assemble here from every land and they're
eager to cross the river,
et Cetera.
But I really want to focus on this
image of the autumn leave whereby Dante
describes that dead souls as the leaves
in autumn that had fallen from the tree.
And the conceit is that the souls are
leaves and it's an image that Dante takes
straight from the need of Virgil.
When books six, also virtual describes
the book, six of your need, uh,
focuses on the descent
of engineers into hades.
And there he also weights and he sees
the souls waiting for reincarnation.
The famous theory of the met them
psychosis, you may have heard this term,
she doesn't mean it's a
reincarnation of the soles.
The souls are waiting to be reincarnated
and come back in an endless cycle.
And in Dante,
virtual himself had taken this
emerge from Houma of course,
but Dante changes Virgil's the thrust
of Burgess image because in Virgil it's
quite accurate.
He has a Pythagorean
understanding of existence.
They say life is a complete,
a continuous circle.
The we love becoming Plato's
we'd of becoming time goes,
goes on and on.
Returning on itself,
we always witness the circle and cycle
of the seasons and this is also what
happens with human life.
There's nothing really unique about us
because we die and then we can wait for
the reincarnation of our soul.
Okay.
So death in Virgil is
an Ilit Jaya experience.
It's never really tragic and cannot be
tragic because it lacks that edge of the,
the uniqueness there.
Yeah.
Just something particular and special
has been happening to the world because I
am here certainly to my world because
I am here and then I made this appear.
Okay. Dante changes this
idea of the circularity,
the [inaudible] quality of death
and life that we have in virtual.
Why do I call it a giant?
Because you die and yet you can come back.
Because we're really like leaves and
justice leaves fall in the autumn.
You just wait for the spring where
I will not be the same leaves,
but leaves very much like
those that have just fallen.
We'll return them to
look about Dante does.
Dante goes on focusing on the idea of the
uniqueness of every leaf as in autumn.
They leaves drop off one after the other
till the branch sees all the spores on
the ground. So first of all,
the wicked seed of Adam.
So the we there is already some kind of a,
some evil,
uh, being acknowledged at the root
of, of, of, of our own existence.
The wicked seed of Adam flinging
themselves from the shore,
one by one at the signal
Sfr corner that's recall,
that's the depart of the dark water.
And before they have landed on the other
side of fresh crop crowd collected.
And then, uh, on this. So for Dante,
this image shows not that leaves
our souls are like leaves,
but that a leaf can be described.
This is soul.
Only few insist on it's own uniqueness
and the fact that it will never return.
That is one con fairly contemporary
report who understood this.
And I really want to
quote to you a few lines.
I don't know that I remember the ball.
It's Gerald Manley Hopkins.
Some of you who have read, who read
English literature. Remember this,
you may remember this.
He writes his famous poem called
Golden Grove Margaret Golden Rule.
You know the poem, you know what
I'm talking about, Margaret,
are you grieving over Golden Grove and
leaving leaves like the things of man you
care for?
Can you are as the heart grows old or
come to such sites called et cetera
continues. What is Hopkins? Who
really is reading this image?
What is he really saying?
He Sang, he understands.
It leaves like the things of men.
You care for Kenya,
what comes back.
It's not the life of human beings.
What comes back at the things that human
beings may use and waste those things
so that the right analogy for Gerald,
Gerald Manley Hopkins in a sense really
in the wake of Dante is between the
things of man,
the things that we have that the things
that we can produce and leaves not
souls.
In formal terms.
This really means that Dante is replacing
the notion of epic circularity that
you find in the classics, the classics
of Homer, the clocks, classics.
How such as the Aeneid
with an idea of linear,
novel,
the life of human beings is best described
the formerly by a novel in the sense
that we are caught in
a journey that goes on.
It's unique and will reach its
destination, whatever it will be.
We don't know yet at
this point of the poem.
And now Dante enters into the
circle, into the, the garden,
the first experience in book
and Canto for, uh, I will, uh,
I want to give you some time to,
uh,
but I will have to deal with Canto
fall and then I will stop after to come
straight to the point about Canto for,
uh,
Dante comes to what is
called limbo are the,
a word that comes from Latin in Latin.
That's what the limbo is. This is, uh,
uh, the edge. That's what it means.
Lambros you're usually in Italian,
you speak of the lay of the lenders
of the air, the edge of, of a,
or a dress or my jacket and so on.
Uh, uh, comes to the area of health,
which really is outside of her. In
fact, it's a, it's, it's, it's a, it's,
it's very much like,
uh, the Virgilian, uh,
afterlife of the virtuous and here he
meets a lot of which it's described as a
garden, one of the gardens,
one of the three, four gardens.
You find sort of pre figuration of the,
in many ways of the earthly paradise
and Gardens in, in purgatory,
but it's also prefigure aeration of
the world, of, uh, of paradise, where,
where the city Jerusalem is
described as a garden. Uh,
so the first thing about this,
uh, uh, it's called, uh, the, uh,
it's called the locals are Mainers,
uh,
in case you want to know
what the technical serve, uh,
low who's Aminos, uh, the
kind of idyllic place.
Uh,
and at that,
this is a term of first theology that
belongs to my very much the epic world.
And in the epic world of reasons
later in the renaissance, uh,
whether it's going to be spent her or,
or even Dasso or Milton,
there's always the story of the hero who
reaches this idyllic bucolic place and
relax. So it's really appraised
of the breakdown of the, the, the,
ah,
Everence hailed as the hero of the,
the adventurous spirit and all his shows.
So this is the irony in
Luther restructures that
whenever heroes seem to look
for a pause to the quest by
reaching the garden and relaxing,
that's where they find out they are
in the most dangerous situation.
That whenever you think that you are
safe and you can disarm and there's,
you know, there is uh, uh,
the running cool water of the river that
is the shade that is the fragrance of
the landscape. This is the way that, where
the w the, the, the where with all the,
the, the, the, the, the, the
description of this bucolic gardens.
That's exactly when the snake will appear.
That's exactly when the enemy will be
capable of reaching you and overwhelm you.
And this is also, in other words,
there are all his places of temptation.
And that's what happens
here. Dante here, uh, uh,
arrives and he sees the poets cantal for,
it's an extraordinary,
they're all virtuals Hayden's,
he sees the poets and the
breakpoints poets that, uh, uh,
uh, he will see the first post that he'll
see are, first of all, he is all the, the,
the, the figures from mark. He
will enumerate the characters,
scientists, philosophers from
the Greek and Roman world,
but put a little bit at
the edge. You know, the,
the real don't seem to have much impact
on the situation here. But then, uh,
the dramatic situation
is when he, uh, uh, uh,
lines 80 and following, uh, or you, uh,
he sees the poets,
the classical poets from
homer to Horace and Ovid,
or you who Horner owners,
both science and art,
who are these two have such honor that
it sets them apart from the condition of
the rest. And he said to me, the
virtual speaking, the honorable fame,
which resounds in their life are both case
against favor in heaven, uh, et Cetera.
Honor the loft deport.
He has his shade returns that left us
with the voice had paused and there was
silence as a footbridge shades coming
to us. The looks were another sad,
no joyful. It's be fit. Limbo.
This is really like life here.
Uh,
that's what the afterlife
is in Dante's conception.
It's only an extension or we
choose to do on this earth.
If you really think that what life, the
beauty of life, which is not a bad idea,
is talking about having endless
seminars of aesthetics, a poetry.
It's this poet's too.
That's what your afterlife is.
You sit down on the sit on the grass
and you go on talking about beautiful
things. He says, he says the good master,
begin mark him that with their with sold
in hand who comes before the three is
there lord, he is homer.
Um, the sovereign port,
he that comes next is Horace,
the moralist,
all of it is the third and
the last looking, uh, famous,
uh,
epic poet,
Dante will again celebrate in purgatory.
Since each shares with me in
the name that one voice uttered,
they give me honorable
welcome and in this Duwell,
thus I saw assemble the noble
school school in Greek means,
uh, it's also leisure illusionary
life scholar, right? This, the,
the, the, the,
the world of play and the [inaudible]
load of lofty song who flies like an eagle
homer above the rest.
And the irony of course is,
is it blind and the Eagle or to
have the sharp, the sharp view,
the sharp vision that they,
Homer's visionaries and then the vision,
right.
He looks he's blind because he's looking
inward in order to know what the psalm
he has to say or be about after the
head talked together for a time,
they turned to me with a sign of greeting
and my master's smiled at this and
then they showed Mr greater honor for,
they made me one of their number so
that I was the sixth among those higher
intelligences. Thus we went home as
far as the light talking of things,
which were fitting for that place in
a widget as well. Now to be silent.
So he is Dante,
uh,
inscribes himself in the history of
western poetry from homer to dance.
He counts himself as sixth.
Among them is Virgil is Luca is all of
it has Horace and of course the master of
them all. Oh, mom. Okay. So
we go from homer to Dante.
It's a little history if you wish of
western Western poetry and Dante things
that he belongs to it.
We could say a number of things about
what they are talking about. He says,
it doesn't say, uh, we talk about
beautiful things which we infer.
We can easily infer. They
talk about poetry, they talk
about their craft, right?
They may be a little link that
I would like you to reflect on,
on your own between the
garden and the kind of poetry,
the kind of beauty that they
are really talking about.
This is the way Dante's imagination works.
You have to pull together things
that don't seem to be described.
So this is the garden. There's some
kind of self absorption about this.
It seems to be a kind of self enclosure.
Part is kind of poetry. It's a,
it's a little scene that reflects on
what their spiritual condition may have
been like.
But what is the most surprising and what
constitutes the temptation of this camp?
The temptation of the scene
for the pilgrims on spiritual
pilgrimage is involved
in a spiritual descent,
which turns out to be a sense.
He says at one point I was
sixth among such genius to see,
do you see the discrepancy? Did you see
how this is jarring? Can you hear it?
He's going down for redemption,
his descending and humility,
and yet now he talks as a poet,
his poetic voices,
one that elevates itself.
There seems to be a kind of
discrepancy between the two.
That's the great temptation of
[inaudible] to believe that is a poet.
He has been claiming that poetry
is better than philosophy.
That porch is like history and the first
concern now he has is to reflect on the
hollowness of this claim.
How this kind of claim about the
importance of poetry can turn out to be a
temptation for him.
It's a Hubris and I, I,
I focus on it as I have focused
on it because in effect,
but we're going to discuss next time canto
five is an extended reflection at way
for Dante to reflect on this claim and
extended reflection on the dangers of
such a claim and the
responsibility of writing poetry.
Dante, we'll meet the great heroine
of all love stories. Francesca,
everybody knows about this.
Fantastic figure, a lovely figure.
Francesca who dies for love,
but Dante's actually encountering a
reader of his own poetry and he witnesses
the kind of traps and,
and,
and risk that reading in price.
We are going to go on next time
thinking about this whole question of,
of reading a responsibilities
of writing the can't afford,
but I can not live without saying
something about the epic quality.
But I've been just talking about,
uh,
I've been defining the poem really is
and novelistic visa vi the circular
structure of uh, uh, uh,
Virgil's understanding of, uh,
the reincarnation and therefore the
great notion of why or what an epic is.
And now I will say,
actually Dante goes on mixing these John,
as soon as you formulate something,
Dante has a way of
undercutting that formulation.
Can't afford ends with a miniature
representation of the epic quality of this
text that goes on enumerating all
the souls that are, he can see,
which is really, as you know,
if you remember from urine, uh,
your ilium on the gates who
really are my one point,
Helen will go on a numbering.
All the ships of the Greeks to old prior.
Remember that scene?
Some of you may remember that, and this
is the weekend or four ends with lines.
Uh,
one 2014 in there before me on the
animal green were shown to me the great
spirits by the sight of
whom I'm uplifted in myself.
I saw electra with men in her company and
you Hector in the knee is and sees us.
So Camilla fantasy layer. So
legislation, King Levenia,
I saw Brutus who drove out
Tarquin Lucrece, Julia, Marsha,
Cornelia.
And by himself I saw
Saladin sign of honor,
the salary and who sits by himself.
I said kind of lofty state.
And when I raised my eyes a little higher,
I saw the master of them, not the now
sitting a minute. Philosophic family,
Socrates, Plato, uh, the other
one was always thoughtful.
Democritus they origin is all the Greek
philosophers. And then Orpheus, Cicero,
lean was Seneca, Euclid Ptolemy. Um, yeah,
it version of classical and cycled PTO.
All of the knowledge is gathered
here and yet to has a website,
keep it in the,
the traditional of encyclopedias.
This formal structures as he want
to organize the world of knowledge.
That is something, one
thing about them. Why,
what's one thing they never tell you?
How you can really educate yourself.
Then never described the process of
education to know that to describe the
process of education,
you got to have an encyclopedic poem
where you are showing the phases and the
stages of learning as the pilgrim.
We'll show, we'll show it twice.
The second thing that I have to say is
that in any enumeration cause you have
here an epic can hemorrhage and that will
close by the marks for the day and you
buy Asians always imply the wish of a
narrative such as an encyclopedia cause
it's a little bit of an
encyclopedic form I say
to encompass the whole of reality.
That's what encyclopedia as one to do
have reality of it intellectual reality
and yet enumerations by the very
virtue of being a numeration.
So we'll tell you that no
total ideation is possible.
That is something that always escaped the,
the,
the four more ordering that,
the encyclopedias one to reach.
And for now, I stopped with my
remarks and we have a few minutes, uh,
in case there are questions
as I hope that, uh, I, um,
welcome questions. So I will
repeat your questions by the way,
for the benefit of the videotape,
Huh?
Please
talks about the first group
centers who were for themselves.
It didn't take a side. Do you think
that was also a political commentary?
Yes. The question is, uh, Dante
talks about the neutral angels are,
uh, he calls him for themselves. So we
say it's by themselves. Uh, and the,
and the question then really is, is
that also a political commentary? And,
and before I could rephrase a, I could
repeat this, the question I said yes,
absolutely.
Down to we'll use the very same experience
for himself later in paradise where
he will say that in many
ways being by one by oneself,
there are times when that
can become inactive virtual.
What are the notion of neutrality
is going to be redefined?
Nancy doesn't like clearly
neutrality, right? Uh, why,
why is he, does he find neutrality? Uh,
because it's the language or provation
for him. It's really a way of, uh, um,
you know, it's, it's, it's,
uh, uh, it's in the, the,
the decision or to take decisions because
we are always making a decision even
when we think of, we are not making good
decisions. You really are. But to him,
that is the sign of a great cover dish.
He explains that in cosmic terms,
this is the metaphysics of the,
the, the Great War in heaven,
which by the way enables me not to say
that it gives the whole of hell a kind of
symmetrical structure because it clearly
begins with the neutral angels and ends
with the encounter with
Lucifer at the end.
So you see that this is really the kind
of what frames, uh, the narrative of hell.
But to go back to your question, when
Dante is going to talk about politics,
he also believed for a while that
he had to take sides. He did.
And he did are going back now to the
few remarks I made about his language,
his political involvement. Uh, on the
first, the first class for seminar,
he was banned.
He was sent into exile and then he removed
himself from more partisan politics.
And how did he do this and what
did he do this for? A while,
he was a wealth being thrown out
of Florence with many others.
Um,
uh,
also as an actor of a punishment for a
decision he had made to throw out the
gibber leans among whom his own best
friend with Okawville Kantor who died in
exile. So he's thrown out and we
do know this historical happenings.
They spend the first few years of their
exile parting and making and going on
through machinations as to how to
get back to Florence and dammit,
really make them pay here,
realizes very quickly the
wickedness of this plan.
He realizes that his own party is
no better than that of the Gibbons.
And so he removes himself from
them that act to removal from the,
the, the criminal violence
that he and his other,
uh,
accomplices were for a while thinking
about turns out to have been madness.
And so he decides in this act of virtual,
uh,
absolute solitude and that is by himself.
So there is a kind of judgment but very
refined and how can you go and really
describing that the s the
act of neutrality is bad.
And yet there is a way in which there
are times where neutrality can become
nothing less than virtuous decision is.
He will make no other questions
please.
I have a question.
Last.
Yes please.
Hello. Uh, friendship and love it.
There was no conversation about loss and
we know from his history they're both,
uh,
both of them
were married, he had children. And I am,
I'm wondering if the physical aspect
of love is irrelevant or the public,
the question refers to the remark,
a remark I made back then was picked up
by a student are also another students.
The remark about love and friendship
as the two are dramatized in a,
in the Vita Nuova and a,
it refers to a wants to know,
actually wants me to explore more the
role of lost since we know that Dante was
married and, and, and a, ah Ha.
What does last have to do with love?
I take, that's really
the, uh, the question. Uh,
and now let me just say that it's a very
complicated question and I will talk
about this next time when we deal with
Francesca who is of course the heroine of
lust, if there's ever one. Uh, and
then we'll see what Dante means.
By that I mean the,
it clearly is an issue related to love,
fundamentally related to love,
but to believe in.
I'm really from Froebel would
confuse some of you here, but don't,
don't be confused to believe that Dantas
judgment of Francesca is limited to the
representation of Canto five where he
describes the relationship between the and
love less than love, uh,
would be a grand mistake.
Dante understands,
understands that without
physicality there can be no love,
uh,
that there is no soul which
is not connected to a body.
In fact, some of the remarks that
I made today are really about,
can be construed.
I did not make the point,
but can be construed as his sense
of the inevitability of the body.
That the intellect in and of by itself,
this whole inner itself
without materiality,
without some degree of being wedded to
the body is really not a part of the
human experience.
So this is what I was saying to them about
the fact that the journey is not just
an intellectual journey, has to be done
in the body, is part of his sense of uh,
the, the inevitability of
the body. And after all,
this is really what his
Christianity is about. Uh,
it's about the incarnation is
about the being embodied, about,
about the divinity being embodied and
therefore entering our human human
condition. Let me also say that Dante
goes on thinking about Francesca.
He condemns her and Francesca is
always circling around in the state of
permanent desire with bowel over
those, by moving around. Yeah,
they really describe me, the
unquiet hearts. If you are,
when you are at peace,
you just stop and sit.
She just goes on moving around and
the round, that's their punishment.
And yet he remembers her
when Dante reaches the habit
of metaphysics in paradise
and his to talk about
the kiss of creation,
how creation God creates the world by
imprinting a kiss on the material that he
had at his disposal.
And the language that he will use is
going to be the language of Francesca.
And that to me means that the case of
Francesca can also be construed as the
existential, um, our counter to gods,
the gods kiss on creation and say,
wait,
I don't think that he's
redeeming her there.
There's no such a thing as the
redemption for the infernal souls.
And yet there is an idea that is something
that may have gone wrong and we have
to see what it is. And it's not the last
we have to see what the situation is.
It's not the last, uh, I don't
think it's homely lost. Uh,
and that is part of,
or there's something even
larger at bought her.
What the mistake that she seems
to be making is of a different,
so the, I keep you hanging
until next time, so that, uh,
otherwise, what's the point? It will will,
uh, uh, we have total to Luca Canto five.
Let's read Canto five for next Tuesday,
but before you go, uh, there's,
there's some time, some case they
are, they have a couple of minutes.
Other questions
please
is talking to Virgil.
He says you're the only one in my
writing through the normal stuff,
which I had been,
uh, it's how he says, oh,
so he's saying that he's,
that he's taken his style from him and
that stop or what she's been with for
which he's gained honor. He's not
honored as an epic poet. He's not,
that's not what are the
implications of what I'm saying?
Okay. The, the,
the question is referenced in the
encounter between the pilgrim and,
uh, the pilgrim and virtual in candle
one over, uh, over in federal way.
Dante, in what I call the
Cup Tatsuo Benevolence. We,
we're capturing the benevolence
of virtual, the only living,
he doesn't even know if it's a shade or,
or a human being.
It turns out that he's a
human being. He says, well,
you are the poet from whom I took car.
The style that has honored
that has made me on her.
And the, the, the salt of
the, the real question is,
this is a little bit of a
lie, isn't it? Because Dante,
but this time is not really
known as an epic poet. Uh,
I would really say [inaudible] I say
it's part of the simulation rhetorical
simulation of a, of, uh,
capturing the benevolence of the listener.
At the same time.
It's really an
acknowledgement, uh, of, uh,
Virgil's mastery and
what is virtuous mastery.
Um,
you know,
Dante really thought that his own poetry
is that Latin is not a dead language,
that the vernacular is really
the way Latin has become in time.
So they continue with the, between
Virgil and him. It's real, it's real.
So there's a kind of continuity
of poetic continue with it. Uh,
but you're quite right that it's
literally, it's not true at that point.
Dante's more of a province,
our port or the portal follows the still
novice to the poets of the sweet new
style from Bologna and Florence.
Then, uh, then Virgil. Yeah.
But thank you so much.
We'll see you next time.